i showed joey that i slammed my penis in
the car door i don't understand
it's not about understanding it half the
memes right that's how it always starts
though you don't understand the meme
when you first get introduced yeah but
you you understand it
through a weird repetition and
kind of mutual
respect of
not really understanding what the [ __ ]
is going on right it's kind of funny but
like you know most memes is like you
know you can change it up a bit you know
you can make a derivative i don't know
how much you can derive you'll be
surprised it's like a whole steamed
ham's thing right that gets that's true
that got like it it can be pushed as
much as it wants to by the way welcome
to this episode of the trash taste show
i don't know what episode we're on not
that we say that
show
i guess we just like found ourselves in
a topic before we even like started
started the show but welcome i'm your
host connor with the boys joey call this
segment nice [ __ ] yeah in the in the
time no no we'll there we'll go
because like
like going back to the memes i just like
i don't understand why i find things
funny anymore like i just some sometimes
like i don't know why bass boosted
things are funny but like it just it
just appears in them sometimes so i just
like laugh i think we're slowly breaking
down the human psyche and the human
consciousness and what what is
objectively funny and for some reason
seeing an orangutan and and some men
going up oh stinky seems to always make
me laugh and i can't tell you why
there's no deeper meaning i'm just
[ __ ] stupid and i've been hacked by
this system that somehow works against
me it's just like the perfect science of
just like the right noises and the right
images you know it's bad when i could
show that to a five-year-old and they
would be unamused but i'm there just
pissing myself like like crying laughing
and it's like what has happened have we
been hacked in a way that like allows
our brain to revert to like one years
old and find things funny because i
don't know anymore i don't know i just i
feel like the internet's just like
broken our sense of humor like why is
the peak of internet comedy just
perfectly cut screams like that that's
that is just like never not i know but
why is this so funny like i hear it i
hear a scream i i sleep if you cut it
just once like a millisecond in it's
[ __ ] like comedy because imagining
the disaster is way funnier than seeing
a disease
like it's like you know you've probably
seen a lot of videos right where there's
like punch lines where people use like
massive explosions yeah like the
punchline yeah but you never think like
uh so like what was that explosion
was that uh
what was blowing up people died yeah
like you know you're like explosion
gabriel you know yeah
stuff is way funnier when you don't have
when you can imagine what happens that's
true in some aspects right like what do
you think is a meme that will just like
you'll find funny in five years any wii
sports meme for me like the moment that
music starts playing i'm i'm like before
the joke even starts the moment i hear
the music it's already fine i'd like to
think when i'm 50 years old that there's
somebody i can go to and i'll be like
what's nine plus ten
and then i'll be like
twenty-one
yeah the same way that my parents
mentioned some weird 60s bbc show that
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't know that spotted thing yeah
this i'd like to think that's what it's
going to be like you know yeah or
someone you know they'll be like so no
head and i'm like 16 i'm like pissing
myself
i i i i we're in this weird time where i
i think humor is going to be so [ __ ]
in like oh yeah i mean it's [ __ ] month
by month let alone what it's going to be
like in like one or two years
of all humans there's going to be like
some morse code jokes or something yeah
probably you know yeah
we're just going to do it just [ __ ]
pierce ourselves it's going to be like
visual like
what is it braille
yeah
and then he said and it's like just
braille on the screen we're gonna be
like pissing it and it's gonna be like
that's gonna be that just sounds like a
hilarious meme that could yeah
this is where memes are going bass
boosted braille
[Laughter]
and it's weird because being friends
with someone like chris right is that
where chris is just on the chris is in
the weirdest spot i think because i've
shown memes to chris where chris will
break down laughing yeah and they're
absolutely stupid but i've also shown
him memes where his boomer side comes
out right like what is this what is this
nonsense why is there flashing noises
and deep fried what is that what do you
know what i mean like chris is in that
that really interesting spot where he's
like chris can be a boomer when he wants
to be a boomer but he also enjoys gen z
here yeah that's true and uh i find i
find that really interesting
because i'm i'm totally like i'm my
humor is so [ __ ] now yeah i only laugh
at stuff when it's like bass boosted and
farting noises
because
i i i like
i feel like i feel like i'm a child yeah
yeah i i feel that because i it's gotten
to a point where i don't know why i find
the things i do funny i just know i find
it funny and there's no like formula to
it there's there's no there's nothing i
can break down to be like ha ha that was
why the punch line was funny you know
you can't explain half the means yeah
the problem is it's if you have a
favorite comedian you can be like watch
their stand-up special yeah if i'm if i
find like
i base boosted uh daffy duck slamming
his penis in the car door with crap of
the rapper there how the [ __ ] do i begin
to explain what i'm into just send a
youtube link
trust me this is 10 million views it's
funny here's the problem with sending
people weird-ass memes like that it's
like and i've had this because i've been
on i've been on the receiving end of me
i think everyone has yeah i'm like what
the [ __ ] is this yeah
and uh it's just this we've turned
comedy into this weird kind of niche
where it's like
it's it's like the equivalent of liking
some weird german techno bend now and
it's like that's what that's what comedy
is now because because to get like a lot
of the most funniest memes to me is it
takes like 10 layers of memes
yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's something
that if you're not invested in this one
like one meme aspect then you're not
just you're just not going to get the
meme because they're just going to be
right the joke of the meme is like a
reference to another joke and another
meme and so on and so forth so it's like
what the [ __ ] is this coffee hold on
does your coffee taste weird what does
it taste like
what's wrong with it tastes like coffee
what kind of is it instant coffee
no it's not oh it's very oh what the
[ __ ] coffees
usually makes is it really that's some
that's some bass boosted coffee
this is what i've described as a crunchy
coffee yeah let me see
have you had these coffee before no what
do they do sorry sorry i
threw me off yeah
sure go ahead go ahead the coffee coffee
review with navi
oh it's
it tastes stale yeah did the nespresso
let us down what's what's going on is it
is it the milk the trailer is in the
middle of the operation send in the
presses find out what happens
that's funky like i just don't bother to
try and keep up with memes anymore just
because like it's like i already thought
the [ __ ] ugandan knuckles meme went
by so goddamn fast and now i've realized
that uganda knuckles sticking around for
a month it's like a feat of
accomplishment for me i mean i mean i
still find you can get into knuckles
yeah i think five years ago
it's even quite different from how memes
are now
now
i feel like okay five years ago we had
memes and we had like three or four that
were pretty big
you wouldn't really hear about other
memes but now there's always like 10
memes going on at once maybe one of them
will kind of get somewhat mainstream
yeah yeah and even then i don't even
mean mainstream like normal audiences i
mean like like on the internet the
twitter sphere yeah yeah yeah yeah
because there are so many memes like if
you ever watch uh lesson and beam
culture do you watch that channel nah
guy just discusses memes and there's
like every day there's a new meme yeah
but most of these memes live and die in
the week and i don't consider that yeah
if this is a niche thing that gets used
a little bit in some communities and
doesn't really take off
i'm like yeah there's you don't really
need to keep up with this because it's
it's it's it's scarcely anything to to
give a [ __ ] about yeah find out why
because we're using almond
not soy milk no no this doesn't taste
like almond milk no i use almond milk
with my coffee that's that's almond i
bought it it's the coffee that tastes
weird is it i think it's i think it's
the combination of the almond and the
coffee probably yeah i mean like if
there are some memes that you see and
you're like this is gonna die off within
two days yeah because i feel like if a
meme is
easily too easily replicated that like
your mom could do it then it's not a
good meme you know what i mean also i
feel with like some memes it's like okay
the like a video with like 10 million
views pops up it's like cool that went
viral but it's like you can't do
anything else with it yeah so it just
ends up being this one video that has a
lot of views
it gets forgotten at the time i think a
perfect meme right is one meme when you
initially watch or discover it you think
this is [ __ ] stupid yeah and then
third time you're like okay have you
witnessed a perfect meme yet
as as the meaning i think vocabulary
does that quite a lot like the word like
buzzing yeah yeah i
i actually despised it when i first
heard it yeah somehow it just grew on me
yeah now i find it hilarious i don't
know why i can't stop saying it and like
deez nuts yeah like these nuts is not
funny like scientifically speaking dees
nuts is not funny
i will laugh every goddamn time i'll
find any opportunity it's one of those
memes where you you laugh and you like
hate yourself for life yeah yeah you
know what i mean it's like dabbing yeah
well it's it's the modern equivalent of
whipping yourself yeah but mentally yeah
yeah
you have to schedule a better help call
after this i i feel like a lot of a lot
of memes now are also like platform
dependent like there are like so many
like tick tock trends and tick tock
memes that i like are massive on the
platform but like we don't we don't like
get exposed to it at all and feel like
it's only like the super if like it's a
super super big meme if it like goes off
of the tiktok platform and you see it on
twitter or on like youtube as well